this is what I've been looking at from
the satellite now for four weeks this is
it what is it doing here
in the middle of nowhere Andrew looks
for further clues in the satellite
images there are a number of holy sites
in the area half a mile away lie the
ruins of an ancient Abbey last refuge of
a secretive 12th century Christian sect
known as the white canons in the shadow
of schapp abbey and who finds two
craftsmen gentlemen hi there using
historic building techniques to patch up
buildings that go back to the 13th
century
limestone get broken up into small bits
yeah and it would make a lime kiln and
build a fire right and burn the stone
lime kilns existed in the earliest human
civilizations Mason's used them to
perform a kind of alchemy in which
intense heat turned limestone into a
substance known as quick lime used for
construction and also as a weapon of war
the heat of the fire by nine degrees
right 36 hours when it comes down to
they're known as quicklime when you add
glue water do it you'll see a quick
reaction pretty instant yes
the craftsmen have provided the clue the
likely purpose of the structure becomes
clear I can't believe it I can't believe
it's not an ancient sacred site it's a
lime kiln the crash like scar in front
of the kiln was probably a ramp for
moving heavy limestone the Masons who
built and operated kilns like this
belonged to guilds that guarded their
secrets closely and claimed secret
knowledge from Egypt and biblical times
when it comes to actually making
quicklime not everyone would have known
how to do this there would have been
keepers of the chemistry alchemists who
were in charge
quicklime was used in the construction
of large monumental buildings and it's
no coincidence that very close to this
site is a large Abbey Church the secret
knowledge of the Masons considered magic
at the time was based on centuries of
experience there quicklime was so
effective it allowed some of the
greatest architectural wonders of the
world to remain standing for centuries
look how solid look how secure this wall
is 800 years later what's really sad is
the rest of the place is in ruins the
abbey is ruined
not because it was badly built but
because of the historic assault on the
monasteries by England's first
Protestant King Henry the eighth
but quicklime also had a darker use